welcome to the
vcast um live in the bleacher report app
we've got a lot to talk about today man
um first I want to address the fans that
have have been asking how it feels to be
back on the field and I will say it
feels great it feels great to be back in
the general population because I was uh
in solitary confinement for so so long
man and um you know I you know it wasn't
it wasn't bad but will I like to be
playing football yes I would love to be
playing football instead of rehabbing my
knee um London I I felt like it was just
a you know me just getting in the water
and I think uh I started to swim a
little bit this week this last past week
versus the Giants and as long as I keep
taking steps like that I am fully
confident that I will be able to um
become the player that I was again um it
just it's just about taking little steps
at a time man um ACL surgery is is is no
joke but it is kind of easy though I
mean it's 2023 like I wouldn't wish this
on anybody but if you happen to have you
know ACL surgery it's 2023 is not really
that bad you just got to sit down a
little bit um but I'm I'm still you know
trying to work and develop and get back
to the player I was but it feels great
you know we're we're playing the
Patriots this week and um I am excited
to take another step this week versus
the Patriots
but it's time for a very special guest
on the vcast um three-time Super Bowl
champion Super Bowl MVP he holds the
record for Super Bowl punt returns one
of the most clutch wide receivers in the
history of our league Julian
Edelman thanks for joining my boy thanks
for joining my boy all day all day do I
still have the past to call you vonie
because I remember the first time we met
I called you vonie by joking around you
said hey man only the ladies call me
vonie
that's my that's actually my real name v
o n n i e that that is my real name um
and of course man you could you could
call me Vonny man only my friends from
back home and people that been knowing
me a long time I've been knowing you for
a while man you could call me Vonny and
of course you know the ladies do call me
do call me Vonnie man but I appreciate
you for coming on man you're a podcaster
now I'm a podcaster um tell us about you
know life outside of the league man what
what have you been up to it's been crazy
man like
when you retire everyone thinks you
retire but it's more of a transition you
know we we've built such a a cool life
for ourselves that it gives us the
opportunity to explore other things I'm
working on you know fox in the morning
on Sundays I'm doing my own podcast game
with names and then I'm being a pops you
know there there's it's it's the first
time you can say yes to things when you
when you're done you're out of the
league and you know you used to have the
excuse oh I got you know I got OTAs I
got mini camps I got training camp I
can't do it I gotta sleep I you know
what I mean it's the first time you can
you could do things so you know
retirement's cool transition's cool I'm
I'm really enjoying to get to see my
daughter every day and watching her grow
and being you know more involved in her
life so it's been fun
man that's cool man that's cool man when
you retire you know you you got a lot of
time to play golf you know I heard you
like to play golf I love to play golf
I've been playing golf for you know two
and a half years now um I heard you love
to play golf maybe a little bit too much
nah you know we got a clip of you uh
with Brady's
driver no whenever I'm with him bro
Badness looks like somebody need
[Laughter]
driver driver the good news is we won
the Super
Bowl that that was actually in uh that
was in Montana every year used we used
to go to Montana for the 4th of July or
or you know right before Camp to get
some training in and whenever you're
with Brady it's training and then you
Golf and then you eat like an avocado
ice cream or something something along
that whole tb12 method so you know when
I'm around him a bunch I golf I don't
you know right now it's crazy you know I
need to get on the course a lot more
because you know a lot of deals are done
on the course but it's tough man I'm
like a soccer dad and stuff I'm taking
my daughter soccer practice I'm watching
we got soccer coach you then after that
you know you're recording podcast so and
then on Sundays weekends during football
season I'm still working so it's it's
it's football season when it's the off
season for me uh you know I'll probably
get on on the course
more man I I I love to play golf man I
this is a uh a podcast about a current
football player talking about you know
current moments in the league and
talking to other football for football
players former and current um but I like
to talk about golf yeah I I Dam there
talk about golf every single show I just
love everything about it man like you
said it's a lot of deals done on the um
on the golf course and for me it's just
having that challenge again having that
to be able to go out there and compete
and get better and you know to to go
into it and not be good at it and and
develop and take a step here get a new
driver a new putter check out new walls
like uh a new bag like visiting other
golf courses it just gives me nothing
gives me that that kind of uh you know
how you get those nerves like before a
game like nothing does that for me but
golf it does get like the competitive
like juices floring for me you I mean
it's an outlet for competitors to
compete with themsel no matter what
you're doing you don't have to be
playing with other people you could you
could be chipping balls in your backyard
you could be playing ppck game you know
at your house or whatever you go to
miniature golf you're always competing
with yourself and that's the cool thing
about golf you know it's not so taxing
on the the body even though when you see
you're you're out of the league all
those little things that you had you
could feel it in your golf swing you
know the more you don't take care of
your body like you do as a professional
athlete you know when you're an athlete
and you're in the game and you're Pro
you're getting body rubbed down twice a
day you know you're sleeping you're do
you know now you take all that out and
you do it maybe twice a week you start
to feel that ACL you had eight years ago
that broken foot you had 10 years ago
you know it's crazy but it's it's a fun
Sport and it's a it's an awesome way to
compete with yourself for sure man you
know I'm I'm a huge Tom Brady fan like I
almost got a Tom Brady tattoo it was uh
it was going to be like the twi 12 and
like the Patriots number type of uh like
that type of Nu numerical font and I was
going to get like a 18 in like the
Broncos like number font and at the last
minute I was like no I might as well
just cha just just save this spot for a
future day man but I love Tom Brady and
I know you love Tom Brady too what was
it like you know playing for the goat
I'll tell you right now first off and
foremost I I I I could probably promise
you that Tom Done doesn't love you
because we used to have to change snap
counts because of you I remember we were
playing you in 2013 in the AFC
Championship we're sitting there like oh
we want it to be a snowy day Peyton
can't grip the ball this that it's 75
and Sunny and Von Miller was in our back
field before he even said goddamn Hut I
remember watching it I was literally I
was in the slot and I go and I'm looking
at the ball and you were already in the
back field before I got off my first
step I'm like oh my God it's going to be
a long day so uh but with Tom man it was
it was awesome to get to play and be
part of his story I mean it's it's a
it's an honor he's the greatest to suit
him up man he's he's an ultimate
competitor but he's even a better person
he's an unbelievable Family Guy you know
I've learned so much on how to be a
professional with him you know taking
taking your craft and really living in
that craft but also being able to
compartmentalize you know and and
separate your craft from when you have
to you know you have your family time
and being able to live other other lives
you know putting all those different
hats on he's like the best at it like
when it's football time he was all
football and then when you know he's a
family guy he was family I learned a lot
of that from him uh and he's just an
awesome dude he's a nice guy he's like
awkwardly nice like where you're sitting
there like dude you can't be that nice
you can't be that nice Tom you really
can't he knows everyone's name you just
he's the guy that you like you want to
hate but you're you meet him in real
life because if like other fans are like
we hate this guy and then anyone who
meets up in real life they're like I
can't hate him he's that guy yeah yeah
100% man like I said it I said it uh so
many times man like the only reason not
to like Tom Brady is because he wins
like and that's not a good reason to not
like somebody like I've I've I think
really for me what really made me really
like what made me um what made me really
like Tom Brady's when we were at the
Kentucky Derby and um I I well I think
you were there too I think I think you
were at the Kentucky Derby you know I
ran into Tom and I was I was talking to
Tom it was kind of I think we at like
this this club or something wherever we
at man he was just so cool man like he
was smil he was happy like man V come
over here man it was so cool man I was
like damn like Tom Brady is super cool
man andon the next day um you know I
think uh for for CBS they they haven't
had a Tom Brady interview in years and I
was doing like lifestyle I was doing
like uh color commentating like on the
Kentucky Derby and the whole spectacle
of the thing and I was like hey man can
you can you ask Tom for an interview
like he never does it and I was like man
I ask Tom Brady I went over to ask Tom
Brady he said yes immediately and we had
did the interview and it was the first
time he had done it like one on National
Television for like in like 10 in like
years and everybody went crazy man and
that's why I really like start to like
Tom Brady I'm like bro he like super
cool to achieve all the things that he
has and you know to be Tom Brady and you
know have all these things surrounding
you man like he is really a down toe guy
he's a he's a normal guy man he just
loves his craft he loves to win I he
loves he love he loves hanging out with
his guys man and I just felt that energy
like coming off of him man and
immediately there in that moment man I
fell in love with Tom Brady man but
defending him on the football field was
another um was just a whole another
thing man you and you and Tom Brady
whenever we played um the Patriots I
always felt like he just if it was like
a weakness in our in our defense he saw
it immediately I felt like he saw it
like immediately if we was blitzing he
knew like okay I'm going hit the pocket
right behind the blitz if we weren't
blitzing if we were playing Z onweather
it felt like he knew exactly where to go
with the ball um he did the ball for me
a couple of times like I I I appreciate
it I appreciate Tom for doing it I I
think I think he's the third most
quarterback that that I that I've uh
that I've sacked in my career he did
hold the ball a little bit and I
appreciate him for that we played a lot
we played a lot we played a lot that's
you know we played a lot we played a lot
bro I played Tom Brady I played Tom
Brady for for 11 years for sure man but
it was super tough playing you guys it
was super tough you know playing the
Patriots in the golden years man um you
guys were were both known for mental
toughness um how did you guys like
sharpen each
other uh I think it was you know just
through the the Reps that we had
together uh and practice you know W with
Tom
like every practice had a purpose it
wasn't like we were just out there just
to lube up the arm Lube up the legs and
and and you know throw the ball around
like he he always had something that
wanted to work on and he was very
meticulous and a perfectionist when it
came to it like he practiced his nuts
off and as a guy you know that that was
trying to you know get into
that culture you know when you're a
young guy and you see the number one guy
doing it you know you you fall in line
and and I think that's where we
connected a lot because I was a
competitive guy that liked to practice
we practiced a lot together you know
with the team you know in the offseason
in different destinations we'd go and
practice and and that's where we fell uh
that's where I fell in love with him Bon
you know that's that's that's where he
got me you know no but uh that's dope
man he got me at the he got me at the
Kentucky Derby man he got you in
practice man he gets everybody he's got
an aura when you meet him isn't he he
got that aura he got that chin and stuff
and he's got those those blue eyes and
he's dressed up like he's probably said
something swaggy Tom Ford something like
the dude is cool hey Tom man hey hey Tom
man if you're watching this man we love
you man hello man yeah hey Tom if you're
watching this you know I appreciate you
doing an interview for Vonnie and you
know I played with you won three Super
Bowls with you and you still haven't
come on my podcast so thank you Tom I
love
you hey it's all love man I'm sure you
do it man but let's let's get into it
man it was a huge week of upsets in the
NFL you know the Jets took down Philly
for the first time in franchise history
you know the Browns wrecked the 49ers
perfect record it really came down to
that last last kick you know but it it
felt like it felt like the Browns were
in control of that game for the most
part the whole game what game surprised
you the most
um I mean those were two surprising
losses you know for Philly and San
Francisco but a lot of it had to do with
you know you're in this third the third
part of the Season you know third of The
Season's done and the the excitement of
the Season being there early on you know
like when the season first starts
everyone gets exited and then there's
the grind the grind starts about week
six to about week 10 that's when it's
hard you don't feel great getting out of
bed you know injury start to to play a
place in the season and I think that's
exactly what happened with Philadelphia
and San Francisco I mean Chris mcaffrey
for San Francisco he's knocked out they
they call plays completely different you
know then Debo Samuel goes out he gets a
shoulder then Trent Brown's out you know
so the fact that they had an opportunity
to still win that game is still pretty
impressive hopefully those guys can get
back because they're going to need them
to keep that well oil machine going but
you know losing at this time of the year
is not always bad you know that and then
with Philly I think it's a combination
of both you know Lane Kenn or uh Lane
got hurt they let their tackle he's been
there you got to see the what's his
they're like they can't win without him
his his record with and without him is
like astonishing crazy uh and then also
I think with the new coordinator you got
John over there with Herz you know
they're still trying to feel each other
out they're a team that really doesn't
have an identity from what I'm looking
at on offense yet you know they got the
tush push and they got every you know
they got the weapons but they don't have
that identity and because their offense
and defensive lines are so dominative
you can you can get away winning ball
games without an identity but you know
it fell in you know if they played
against a hungry team with the good
defense the New York football Jets and
and it and and and ended up hurting them
and punching them in the stomach so
hopefully they learn from that and
hopefully they can keep it get it going
because this is the time of year where
you are what you are we need to start
building on our strengths you know you
got four six weeks down that's kind of
like all right now we got a sample size
of what we do well and what we don't do
well let's let's sharpen these things so
we can get on that run because we all
know the best the best football is going
to be played at the back end of the
season and if you're not playing your
best football 100% that's when you're
watching the games at home during
January so you know those were two
surprising losses but they're not really
surprising the League's got so much par
you know everyone's good in the NFL I
hate when people say you know oh you
lost to this yo they're getting paid too
they got Ballers too they may not have a
superstar or the Superstar hasn't
evolved yet or become something but
everyone's getting paid you got coaches
working their dicks off all can you
swear on
this yeah you good you know working
their balls off all night even if you're
on losing teams or winning teams all
coaches are pretty much you know coaches
work that's what they do so everyone's
trying to win oh man you know so it
doesn't really ever surprise me but it
does tell us things that we need to know
about these teams that did lost
specifically Philadelphia and San
Francisco can Philadelphia get an
identity can San Francisco get healthy
and find ways to win when they may not
have Christian mcaffrey at their
disposal Sometimes using those other
weapons and uh so that that San
Francisco game was a little tricky
because it was a weather game you know
Brock I saw a couple balls slip out of
his hand so that's that's good for a
Young quarterback to feel that you know
he he he I don't think he's probably
played in a weather game yet you know
when you get to have that experience now
he's going to learn from that he's gonna
you know he's going to learn that hey
maybe on a wet week let's let's throw
these balls slick during practice so I
can get my grips and you know there was
a couple times there was a quick snap he
was trying to get a screen out he didn't
get the laces and you know there there's
there's he's got to learn that he he
probably hadn't done in a while so these
are these are good losses for these
teams if they use them right both for
those teams the Browns and the Jets had
strong performances um great D lines
coach uh uh Robert said what is it Sal s
sal sal Salah Shah Salah coach Shah
Salah coach Shah he he said they have
they have embarrassed all the
quarterbacks that he played and I had to
sit back and think about it and he has
like that defense has embarr every
single quarterback that they've played
Patrick Mahomes had two two picks
against
them Herz had three picks and they
didn't have they didn't even have sauce
yet out there so that's impressive and
then who else who else they play Josh do
three do three picks in the first I
mean that all starts from having that
big old guy in the middle that that D
line too because you know what
quarterbacks don't like they don't like
that pressure in the middle of the
pocket they hate that no they don't they
hate that
when guys like you are super fast and
you got a good couple you got a you got
that middle of the pocket they could
step right up you know what I mean if
you can't step up you're done who do you
think the best team in NFL is right
now I'm gonna
go my best football team I think the
best team I don't know if they're the
best football team but who's playing the
best to me is the Detroit Lions uh you
know Goff has had a resurge into of his
career they've gone on the road and won
big games they knocked off the last year
Champs Chiefs opening night on Banner
dropping night that's a big win and they
had you know let up the next week and
and then now they're four straight so
you know Jared gof he's playing Strong
football they could run the football
their offensive line it looks like they
can control games they're getting great
production from their offensive line
which allows the play action to open up
and jerro gof to flourish they got a run
game their defensive line Hutchinson the
kids making big plays they spent that
second overall draft pick last year on
them and and it's finally feeling like
you know it's coming to fruition over
there they're playing you know they're
playing pretty good football and they're
winning on the road so I don't know if
they're the best team in the league but
they're playing the best to me right now
and they playing really good football
man when we played the Lions last year
that was a game where I tore my ACL but
before that game like I felt like man
these guys are good man like from both
tackles on each end on each end of the
field um Jered G was he was playing good
football back then and their defense
they're led by this defense man and this
defense is is is playing really good
football and they're coached by Dan
Campbell he's a he's a fighting Texas
Aggie man and you know I love I love uh
I love coach Campell man and you know
whenever he got the head coaching job I
was like man I don't know if he can do
it I knew right away that Dan camell was
going to have success he has he has
Aaron Glenn over there I think Aaron
Glenn is a defensive coordinator doing
really well so it's a team full of aggas
over there Glenn's been K dud that
defense playing that the defense is
playing very well like a lot better than
they were playing last year and that's
what you want to see from you want to
see progression you know they didn't get
that many new guys on I mean did they I
think they may have got a corner and a
safety I don't think they did they got a
safety from Philly I think um but yeah
man yeah they got they got they got uh
what they got uh Gardner uh Gardner
Johnson yeah he's over there now yeah
yeah they're playing tough man and and
they're taking on the Mantra of their
head coach what does Dan Campbell like
just spit when you think of them mental
toughness you know they're they're a
mentally tough team you know when what
was it Jared goth three weeks ago
against who was it the Packers division
game they're used to losing these games
the Packers come out and score opening
drive Jared gof goes out throws a pick
and then they get the ball back and
what's Jared goof do and you've seen so
much growth in his career he leads the
team down to score right after the
interception where a lot of you know
back in the day you would you his
confidence used to get shook I played
him in a Super Bowl when you know bill
was giving him all these crazy looks you
could just tell he was a little
flustered so his growth and his mental
toughness is it's being it's just being
portrayed out there on in in Detroit and
I I hope they have success this year and
continue this success and they stay
healthy because I think it's a cool
story man Detroit hadn't been good in a
minute you know probably if they they
ever wanton a Super Bowl but like they
haven't been competitive competitive in
a in a long time and it's an exciting
team that has a fan base that loves
their sports that hasn't had as much
success as you know they they want man
they they doing a great job man and it's
all it's all L by Dan Campbell man I
love Dan Campbell let me uh transition
over to the bills Patriots game this
weekend it's going to be a good good
game I feel like like I said before um
there are no slouch teams in the in the
NFL um like Edan said earli in the
podcast like you know everybody um in
the league they get paid you know
everybody's grown me um and it could it
could you always see teams that get beat
that shouldn't have been beat and you
always see teams that that win that that
shouldn't probably win so each and every
week is his own game and when I watch
the the Patriots on film I see the
golden years I see the golden years of
the Patriots I see golden years like
golden years when they had you Tom Brady
gronowski that bills still calling the
same plays it's still the same defense
but I feel like they're they lose the
ball early in games and the game just
gets out of hand early in the game I was
watching film today and they had this
little play action pass to the running
back and usually gron C would be open
right over the middle but you know he
for some reason M Jones just came off
for that look they're definitely not
starting fast which is a problem because
they're built to probably play from
ahead um wi with what they got over
there on offense but you know it's been
a rough year for everyone I think it's a
collective whole unit thing on the
offensive side of ball now I've been
tough on Mack early this year but like
he's not you know one play when Mack
makes a good throw the receiver falls
down one play When the receiver's open
the offensive Line's not protecting like
they're just not compounding good play
after good play let alone just like
doing a regular play you know what I
mean so and then they get into these big
holes and then you throw in
turnovers you know and then you throw
over the Special Teams hasn't been
performing like they have years
past and and then you get this you know
so it's been a tough year it's it's it's
hard to watch I'm sad for everyone over
there because I know the the work that
they put in you know the Matthew Slater
I still he's still on the team he's been
playing forever 15 16 years you know
this got to be tough for him you know
it's a different team there's only a
couple of them from those golden years
that you you you said earlier um so I I
feel bad I hope that they can stack a
couple good plays together let's just
let's just worry about that before we're
think about winning let's just like
worry about like let's stack let's not
have a negative play Let's just not have
a negative play for a drive you know
let's not have a a boneh head penalty
that starts us off in you know first and
15 or you know a holding penalty and
then you're in second and TW or first
and 20 and those are Drive Killers we
all know that then you got guys like Von
Miller with their ears pinned ready to
just take your head off like that's you
can't play like that especially how it's
being coached over there so I think it's
a combination of everything man it's
it's just been a bad year over there and
I feel bad because you know they're
working hard you know you know you know
the stress is high
because of the standard that's been set
there for the last 20 years you know
there's a standard you know so you just
hope and and and you hope that you know
being an outsider looking looking into
it I'm not I'm not in there anymore you
just hope that the leadership you know
on that on that on on that team can can
get these guys to just worry about the
little things you know because that's
really the game that's that's what the
NFL is it take it's not the team that
you know makes the most plays it's the
team that makes the least amount of
mistakes that wins games are lost in the
National Football League they're not one
like it that's really what it is because
everyone's goingon to make a play it's
it's about the play you don't make like
in a bad play that that's what makes a
team win I don't know if you know you
know what I'm talking about B
yeah I know exactly what you're talking
about do so what does the team go from
here do you do you trade M Jones for
Kurt Cousins if if Kurt Cousins if he
removes his no trade clause do you trade
for Kurt Cousins or do you ride it out
with M Jones I would stick it
out you know out they're not going to
pay Kurt next year you know they're not
renting you you'd rent kurk cousins if
you had a
shot you know cuz unless you want to pay
him for the next few years I think you
gota you got to you got to stick with
Mack
and this is where you
see his mental toughness and and you
know when things are not at best a lot
of you know characteristics come out of
people and that's kind of when you want
to evaluate them because that's when you
know you got a dog or not I like Mac
Jones I like M Jones like I see you can
see you can see the talent like you can
see like why he was a firstr you can see
like why people are so excited about Ma
just like you said before on this play
the receiver falls down on this play the
defensive end comes free and he gets
sacked and now we're behind the sticks
like it's just one thing after another
but you can see the talent there with
with M Jones I see it on film like I've
seen it on TV it's just you know it's
just this play or that play and it just
it just sets him back on the sticks um
it's tough though you know like for me
when people ask me all the time it's
hard for me because I've only seen
really one one way and and you know the
guy that I played with Tom like if the
offensive line was struggling that day
he would adjust his game he would get
the ball out quick let's like find a
quick matchup and like you know what I
mean like or if the receiver you know
that he knew how to adjust his game and
it's hard to to give a a true unbiased
take on the whole thing because that's
really all I know you know I I was there
with Cam but that was different you that
was a different year it was weird it was
[__] Co year ain't nobody that Co
year was
weak you know how it goes I was Hur I
was I was hurt the whole I was hurt the
whole year man I I don't that's why I
retired I retired because of
Co I couldn't you couldn't even meet
with people you couldn't eat you were
eating out a little like like take it
take home salads and stuff like what the
[__] is everything was in they started
changing up everything I was I was like
I got it was crazy man you had to test
before you you had to test before you
came in the facility all that man Tariq
has been balling down in Miami um he's
currently on place to break Megatron
single season receiving record um I
think it's I think it's super impressive
man like I think Megatron's I think his
uh his record has been been there for at
least I want to I want to go ahead and
say at least a decade
he said he was going to go for 2,000 at
beginning of the year he has almost
1,000 yards through six games you know
he has 11 games left like it's crazy
what he's doing up there man he's one of
the best wide receivers if not the best
wide receiver in the league like he's
he's he's going crazy man and he's not
doing it with the size he's doing it
with the speed and you know he's still
getting double and triple cover and he's
still able to get open he's still able
to burn guys um he's just he's just a
he's just a great receiver man and you
know I just think that you know he's
just one he's just he's just one of them
ones he's got crazy speed but he can
also get in and out of his breaks so he
can route you up if you try to if you
try to press him and if you back up and
he gets on your toes you ain't G to
catch him so like the combination of CR
and he's like really strong he's not a
big guy but he's explosive like he's got
a strong bottom end like he can shed
guys off and run through guys and he can
get through releases strong and he can
out quii you he can outspeed you he can
out strength you he's only about 5'8
what is he 5'9 like and he can jump he
could jump through like he probably he
probably got like a 50inch vert you know
what I mean like it looks like it for
sure so when you you combined like all
that he he's got a good thing going for
him right now man and I I I think he
could do it he's gonna do it if he stays
healthy he'll do it do it too CU a
six-yard hit trout to him could be that
could be 60
yards all all they need is one person to
miss and obviously that guy that's
guarding him he might be 10 yards off of
him and that's the that's that's the
only that's all the space that he needs
to take it to distance I remember our
first I remember my first time playing
Tyreek Hill um and the KE to leave you
know he was on he was on a Denver
Broncos defense at the time and I
remember after that game the Chiefs they
just killed this I think this was the
beginning of like the little Jet Sweep
where he where Patrick Mahomes like toss
the ball in front of him and Tyreek
catches it and you know the ends
couldn't they they he just flew by the
ends before they even knew what was
happening and I remember the next day
like a t talking about Tyreek K he was
like bro he this ain't no normal just
this ain't no normal just fast receiver
like he he a football player like he can
play said he can play football he's
strong he can f he fast he stiff arm
like he's like bro then hearing that
from a Al Le because two years before
that like we're in the Super Bowl and it
keep saying man these receivers man I I
these these receivers ain't going to do
nothing so to see him give like Tyreek
Hill those type of props man I knew
Tyreek Hill was going to be great man
and that was early on um another
receiver that's been known I love
a I used call him two chains or un chain
cuz he always wore like two chains
before two chain like everyone had two
chains I'm like hey till you got to take
that chain off you only got un chain bro
like hey ju you know he got his high ass
pitch boy hey J what you talking about
oh man he came when he came to the
Denver Broncos man he he wore like
washes and chains and like by the end of
that by the end of that 2015 season
everybody was iced up like he said hey
man like sitting next to me you going
hey you better get you some ice cuz youy
you going to look milky sitting next to
me yeah so by the end of that season man
I'm talking about everybody from Derek
wolf to to uh Emanuel Sanders every
everybody had everybody was iced up man
I speaking I I like that I like that I
like that impression of of of Aid man
and you know I hear you're a master of
Impressions no not for I honestly do
terrible Impressions I just I just
commit to
them I just but if you up for it I would
I I want I would want to you know play a
little game with you man is that cool
man I can give you somebody you can give
me I'm not I'm telling you I ain't no
Frank cendo out out here dude I'm not
like I'm terrible at it but let's
see all right okay what would grank say
about Travis Kelsey and Taylor
Swift yo
Jules can you
believe that Kelsey and Swift are
together like I I just that's pretty
cool like something like that that's
that's kind of what I can't believe you
okay what
what would Bill what would Bill bich say
if you sent him a birthday
present if I sent him a birthday
present
yeah he probably wouldn't say anything
but he would he would probably write you
a crazy he write he he writes you
handwritten letters and he'd be very
thoughtful on it but he like look Jules
like I hope you don't think that I'm
going to get you a present now like what
the [__]
what would what would Tom Brady say if
you invite him on a
vacation if I invited him on a
vacation yeah look babe you know like
babe I I got my kids in in Miami in New
York babe I I'm probably not GNA be able
to make it babe sorry babe I love you
babe next time we go to Bakers I'll I'll
bring you I'll I'll helicopter you there
so
thanks for the invitation but I'll let
you
know hey yeah you got his voice down
perfect what what would what would Randy
Moss say if someone just got
Moss [__] edel nut you know that song A
Star is Born today yep they made that
that that song was made when I was born
and now they saying this about
me 98 first round get to know
me they used to tell me me that all the
time ednut 98 first round get to know me
Randy you're the greatest receiver I've
ever seen I know who you
are 98 first round okay okay what what
will Von Miller say after second Tom
Brady what would what would Von
Miller yeah what would I
say yo Brady you could call me vonie I
only let the ladies call it to me
usually but I love you
man hey man that hey that was perfect
bro like you said bro you a master bro
you're a master of absolutely I'm
terrible at [__]
Impressions man I love to be a bell TR
when Ed the Randy M went man like you
are great man before I let you go man I
got I got one more game for you just one
more you rank third all time in the
playoff in playoff receptions behind
Jerry Rice and Travis Kelsey and catches
you're one of the the best and catches
you're one of you're one of Bro Look at
Kelsey dude he's a
monster he go to the playoffs every go
to the playoffs every year man you are
one of the best playoff performers ever
in the history of our league so I wanted
to build your all-time clutch playoff
team assuming you're you're already on
the roster so you already on this roster
I'm G give you 12 bucks and you have to
build your your alltime playoff clutch
team and obviously Tom Brady is at $5
and we got grank at$ five too so you
could I you could you could use both of
those guys I know you love those guys
but then we had to settle for hin Ward
and marshan Lynch but if you could use
this $12 how would you build your
alltime playoff coach I think $5 is
already going to Tom Brady right yeah
without a doubt I mean it's a
quarterback League gota pay you get the
quarterback right you're GNA be all
right so we're going
TB um now who would te
see Jerry Jerry's too
expensive because you gotta go I I
already know you you gotta go
grank I'll give grank and how is Mara
how is Marshawn a dollar I'm taking
Mara I I didn't set this up I didn't set
this up but and then we got to go with
hin w we got to go with Hines Ward and
you already on you already on roster too
you're already on a roster too so it's
good actually then I got I got to go
back I got to I'm on this roster so I
got to go back ah you already on you
already on the team this this not
including you so do I gotta go Kelsey
and then
to I might have to go but you know
Kelsey see grank up that seam he can
like you know like Kelsey might take
some of my
rocks you know he already got
sobody put back that on grock you gotta
go with Gro and me and hdes
this Tom would I don't know if Tom would
necessarily pick
this this
is I think I think we can win I think we
can win with this I think Hines War
everybody on there them already won a
Super Bowl already man so I think we can
I mean how can Mar only be a
bu you know sometimes you know sometimes
prices drop man this this is a this is
like clearly like this should be a
physical a physical way of
winning you know war going and block the
forest Marsha you know we give him the
ball hit that play action to grank right
up the
scam man that's that's super dope man
like I I can ride with this too man I
obviously I could go
with if I was Brady man if I wouldn't
pick Brady I'd pick
Joe Joe Joe Mont I love Joe I grew up a
ners fan Big Joe Montano fan oh that's
dope so I Joe I would go Joe too Marsh
joh grank if I if I couldn't pick Tom if
I couldn't pick Tom you said is
Joe to Maran Mar
grank we can we can win with if I could
pick
gr then I would go Travis
too
Marsha
Travis Tio
Marsha Tom but this is my team if if I
could pick those
two hey that's dope man I got I got I
got one and two chat questions man they
been going crazy in the chat for you man
um they said Julian besides your Super
Bowl catch in the fourth versus Atlanta
what's your best catch of all time
what's your favorite catch of all time
the third and 14 against Seattle we were
down 10
points it was in the fourth quarter cam
Chancellor lit me up laate across the
middle
that that was my favorite catch it's
kind of like a microcosm of my career
you know just a tough catch take a big
hit get up and finish the drive I like
that
one did you see did you see the the dble
and and did you see dble and Tyra
getting getting into it after the first
half in the Giants game what's the
maddest bellich ever was at
you uh you know Bill
yeah that was some bad situational
football right there yeah that was crazy
yeah I'm not complaining but I'm not
complaining but yeah that
was yeah that was bad uh you know coach
bellich was he wouldn't get on you in
front of people like he would never
during the game there's problems to be
solved and like nothing would get across
from getting on a guy like me now I I'm
you know maybe a quarterback I'm a
receiver I'm I'm a
I'm not the guy leading uh a side of the
ball
so he never really got mad at me I mean
he give you a look I remember I fumbled
the ball against the Giants on a punt
return like my my third year and I I he
just you know he kind of gave me a look
but that's all he had to give me and I
knew he was all he I knew he was mad K7
whoop he said I don't get why Julian
still doesn't have a gold Jack and one
of the best slot receivers at ever
played a game and I completely agree
with that 100% man um I witnessed it um
I even seen you you remember that time
you was on the field and you were
wearing those linen
yeah I tell that story all the time I
broke my foot so I came back with the
broken foot I had these metal plates in
my foot I couldn't I couldn't even run
that game remember and and and vaugh
right when like you kind of knew the
game was they almost had it sealed he
looks at me or it was early in the game
I think you say hey Jules man I respect
your game man but I can't I can't you
got to swag up more on your cleat you
keep you're wearing those Cadillacs or
something you said something like that
those things look like and he was like
man he like man my foot broke my foot
man I was like bro what are you doing
what are you what are you doing man but
I knew I knew your foot was hurt man I
knew your foot was hurt I was just
[__] with you man and like I said
before man like I've I've witnessed it
on the football field man you're a hell
of a player man um hell of a person man
I've get gotten to know you own and off
the football field man it would have
been dope to be your teammate man that's
another thing too before I let you go
man I remember Tom Brady telling me um
at the at the Kentucky Derby man he was
like Hey
man come on down the come on down to New
England I was like whoa hey he does he
know something that I don't know man
like he he might know something that I
don't know I would love to play with
with Tom Brady man what it would I would
have loved to be your teammate man I I
would I think I think we would got along
great man and now hopefully I see you on
the links man if you ever want me to
come on your podcast man you know I got
you man it's all love and respect man
and it's an honor and privilege to have
you on my show get out of here man
you're you're I mean I you still got the
chicken company I remember you telling
me about that like eight years ago at a
we were at the P Diddy party remember
that at uh Ultra in Miami or something
uh dude you're you're a you're a goat
bro I mean I I've witnessed
you uh put me to put our teams out of
the our miseries uh I loved competing
against you you're always a cool dude
every time that we've linked up in the
off season at some function and like the
things that you're doing while you're
playing man that's an inspiration for a
lot of these young guys I mean you're
one of the first guys to have a current
guy playing with the podcast now every
it seems like everyone's doing it and
and you you're a trend Setter dude so
you keep on doing it and we'll link when
you're out in La get you on games with
names everyone who's listening right now
click and subscribe give us a comment in
the section about what game you want us
to do and remember rate and
review all love man I appreciate you G
man thank you man all day I'll see you
[Music]
bro